last time on film theory so there you
have it all three Joker's fit cleanly
into the three Joker comic model but
then that prompts the question now that
Jared Leto is playing the Joker in
Suicide Squad is he a whole new
character or which Joker line would he
be continuing Mobius chair tell me who
is Jared Leto's Joker today conclusion
hello Internet
welcome to film theory with an episode
that's gonna spend more time analyzing
the Joker's Suicide Squad appearance
than the time he actually spent on
screen in the movie seriously it was
like Harley I'm coming for you in a
helicopter but don't let the brevity of
his appearance fool you he's probably
the most important part of the film and
definitely a whole lot more important
than that hula dancing enchantress
because his connection to the three
Joker Theory leaves the door wide open
to some huge revelations about the DC
film universe and where it might be
headed next last time we took a look at
the three Joker theory the fact that the
three live-action versions of the Joker
from the movies perfectly correspond to
the huge reveal in DC Comics that there
were three different Joker's running him
off there's the Jack Nicholson Joker
from the Golden Age the mob boss
mass-murderer the Cesar Romero Joker
from the Silver Age of comics the bank
licensing prankster and the Heath Ledger
Joker from the Bronze Age and modern age
of comics the psychopathic agent of
chaos if you haven't seen that last
episode click on this bat-signal and
grapple hook your way over to that video
but now we tackle the fourth and final
live-action Joker suicide squads Jared
Leto what is he fit into all this
well it turns out that Jared Leto isn't
a new Joker at all he's just a reboot of
one of the prior versions we've already
seen so the question is which Joker is
he
will it be Joker number one Joker number
two or Joker number three
jared leto your dream joker match is the
golden age joker jack nicholson he's a
mobster with a penchant for crushed
purple velvet who'll always keep you
smiling
he loves long walks on the beach and
dancing with the devil in the pale
moonlight but why well just look at the
evidence first they bolt revel and
violence the Nicholson Joker at Jared
Leto both are killers enjoy killing we
see a time and again in Tim Burton's
1989 Batman Jack Nicholson gleefully
incinerating people with electrified
hand buzzers dancing around while
shooting former partners stabbing
political figures in public with
pennsville Bruce Wayne wanders around
the crime scene like an idiot's now look
at Suicide Squad where the Joker is
frequently wielding of a sheet gun
please please spraying gunfire
everywhere throughout the movie we also
see him repeatedly play mind games with
other criminals before either killing
them or having them killed
this means that we can solidly rule out
the Cesar Romero Joker because he was
from the Silver Age but violence and
gore were all the white washed out of
comics he was just the kooky crazy
prankster who used wacky props to rob
banks riders of the Silver Age comics
specifically wanted the Joker to be more
creative resourceful with his weaponry
never resorting to traditional guns and
knives and now look at suicide squads
iconic knife arrangement scene not only
does it reveal Joker's OCD tendencies
and introduce the world to the verbal
equivalent of the slow clap ha ha ha
seriously that laugh is a slow clap but
it reveals that Leto's Joker ain't
showing the same ingenuity with his
armory guns knives or guns more knives
Caesar is out seeing all you guys were
worried that spoiled this video with a
thumbnail from last time pay attention
to this stuff but then what about Heath
Ledger's bronze-age Joker well just
think back to the Dark Knight Ledger's
Joker is a loner insane out of control
answering to
one he appears and dissapears randomly
surprising and often turning on the
gangs who hired him this clearly doesn't
match up with the Jared Leto Joker
I mean seriously suicide squads Joker is
like the Kanye West of Gotham a social
butterfly that traded in as Shutter
sunglasses for a blinged-out grille I
mean the guy hangs out in clubs with his
entourage for crying out loud he has a
girlfriend who it's worth mentioning we
see him risk his life several times to
say he's surrounded by henchmen who act
less like cronies and more like bronies
or I guess just like Bros really it's
the first time that we ever see the
Joker with a social circle or is it
turns out the Jack Nicholson joker
matches Jared Leto when it comes to this
little posse of his just like Leto Jack
is a crime boss with an army of
disposable henchmen at his disposal in
fact both are mob bosses who rule over
organized crime and Gotham they mobilize
huge efforts to do things like attack
art museums or break into
maximum-security prisons and the
important part about all of this is that
these activities have literally nothing
to do with Batman in fact Batman's only
role there is to get in the way of
everything for Heath Ledger's Joker his
goals only ever revolve around Batman it
goes back to what we talked about last
episode the bronze age Joker is totally
dependent on Batman the yin to his Yang
the sun-eater's share the third pairing
that should be funny and isn't coming to
mind right now but the Golden Age
Joker's doesn't his crimes and schemes
planned and Batman is only a roadblock
to completing those so there you have it
Jared Leto's Joker is a reinvention of
the Golden Age oh gee Joker of the
comics the grinning Jack Nicholson as
mobster it's been softly confirmed by
suicide squads director that he went
into the Golden Age Origins of the
character when deciding how the Joker
would fit into this new movies world but
so what I hear you saying but you forced
me to wait on a cliffhanger just for
this excellent question straw man
commenter your patience will be well
worth it because knowing how Leto fits
in with three Joker Theory has some wild
Haitians about the DCU you see one of
the major ways DC's comic universe
differs from that of Marvel's as its
emphasis on parallel worlds the concept
allowed writers the creative freedom to
explore alternative versions of
characters in their histories without
contradicting the established continuity
of the main universe the modern version
of this dates back to 1961 when the
writers of the flash were trying to
figure out a way for Golden Age versions
of characters to appear in stories
alongside their Silver Age counterparts
thus began a story titled flash of two
worlds in which Barry Allen the modern
flash travels to another earth
accidentally vibrating at the right
speed to appear on another planet where
he meets Jay Garrick that parallel
Earth's version of the flash t LDL to
long didn't listen they created parallel
Earth's
to try and explain away the
overcomplicated stories because using
physical cosmology hypotheses is always
gonna make things simpler am i right
yeah who's with me
don't leave me hangin high five years
your screen right now please please
don't leave me hanging I have a
perpetual fear of being left hanging
please by five years screen right now
who thank you anyway the number in
canonicity of these alternate universes
have varied over the years due to DC's
policy abusing or abandoning the concept
at various points in its history with
the number of Earth's going anywhere
between 52 to infinity and beyond first
one is most famous for being inhabited
by the Silver Age heroes earth twos
claim to fame as being the universe
where Quebec is an independent nation
from Canada oh and it's also home to the
Golden Age version of these characters
and then that would leave Earth 3 as the
home to the Bronze Age characters right
yeah I wish that would have made this
episode a whole lot easier to write No
earth 3 is backwards history earth a
world where Christopher Columbus
discovered Europe instead of America and
where morality is reversed showcasing
evil versions of all your favorite
heroes and no I'm not making any of this
up it's basically the DC equivalent of
fanfiction earth if you're looking for
the Bronze Age heroes they're scattered
around the various multiverse timelines
so since we're specifically talking
about Batman everyone's favorite
grizzled rodent themed detective from
the Dark Knight Returns can be found on
earth 31 31 obviously why wouldn't you
think to look there well sorry he was on
earth 31 until a reworking of the
universes made earth 31 home to the
pirate versions of these characters you
think I'm joking but I swear I swear it
is all real
a very general overview of how DC's
comics work but what's it got to do with
the Joker
well DC hasn't been content with just
leaving the parallel universe concept
solely to the pages of the comics from
the very first episode of the flash TV
series the creators have been hinting at
the existence of the DC multiverse
dimensional barrier ruptured unleashing
unknown energies into our world
antimatter dark energy X elements are
all theoretical yes bloody physics
gibberish particles Eureka we've gotten
it but then later that same episode a
newspaper mentions a crisis and red
skies both of these are references to
DC's crisis comics perhaps most famously
crisis on Infinite Earths which are
always these massive events spanning all
of the main franchises where the
parallel Earth's
pirate worlds included crossover to
solve some cataclysmic threats if DC is
building to a franchise crossover on a
scale larger than just this league this
would likely be the type of story they
try to tackle and it seems like they're
interested in since that first episode
the flash has built much more of its
main plot around multiverses including a
visit to earth to season 2 episode 13 of
the flash was a hub of crossovers
confirming a shared canon with both the
Supergirl TV show and another DC TV
franchise legends of tomorrow now during
the last video I brought up DC creative
chief Geoff Johns and how he was a key
player in the cinematic universe as well
as the three Joker review now in an
interview with BuzzFeed he's also
mentioned the magic M word multiverse
quotes
well arrow and flash are the same
universe and we get a lot of great story
out of that especially when we have
episodes that cross them over but that's
also where our superhero universe lives
we look at it as the multiverse we have
our TV universe and our film universe
but they all coexist
so clearly the groundwork for a DC
multiverse exists and is on their mind
but then we have Darkseid as hinted at
is one of Batman's fever dreams in
Batman V Superman the heroes will soon
be forced to fight against a villain
whose signature is the Omega symbol one
of the biggest baddies of DC Comics and
the main antagonist to the Justice
League dark side so very clearly we know
that this guy's coming but based on the
comics we also know that he's a villain
who just so happens to cross multiverses
quite frequently and has been known to
kill off some major players on some of
the
versions of Earth so what does it all
mean well let's look at the three Joker
theory one last time we have a Golden
Age Joker in Suicide Squad and a Bronze
Age Joker in the Dark Knight's we have
an old Batman unafraid to murder in
recent DC movies and also one who is
significantly less murdery in the Dark
Knight trilogy we have a comics
franchise known for crossing over its
multiverses and a movie division
fighting against the juggernaut of
Marvel falling victim time and again to
negative reviews so considering all of
this there's one trump card on the table
for DC that does everything they need it
to do it differentiates them from Marvel
provides huge fan service has the
potential to reset all their missteps
with movie lord delivers a massive box
office and all while still adhering to
their comic roots creating a parallel
universe crossover a crisis event that's
right a christian bale ben affleck
batman team to fight the combined powers
of the mob boss Jared Leto Joker and the
unhinged chaos bringer of the Bronze Age
Heath Ledger equivalents sure Marvel has
its Avengers it's just the Justice
League with different faces but an inter
series crossover where multiple
generations of actors who played the
same character team-up it's the one
thing DC has that Marvel doesn't Golden
Age crossing over with Bronze Age
crossing over with Silver Age for that
matter who wouldn't love to see
Christopher Reeve films most iconic
Superman reminisce with the Man of Steel
over there parallel universe Martha's
everyone loves talking about their
mothers so much and I get goosebumps
just thinking about a lineup of Batman
doing a slow-motion here a walk Keaton
Clooney Kilmer Affleck Bale West act
throwing the kid from Gotham and Lego
Batman he's got a movie coming up - who
wouldn't want to see that it's like
those episodes of Power Rangers where
all the past seasons get together to do
one massive battle except with Batman
and versions of the Joker Pegg while
you're at it throw in Superman teaming
up with pirate Superman to fight evil
Superman long story short the table is
set for an intra character crossover
is with flashes Batman with Batman and
at a time when DC's movies are
undergoing a bit of a crisis a crisis
might just be the thing that they need
to solve all of their problems thank the
three Joker's for that one but hey
that's just a theory a film theory
and cut speaking of epic crossovers
check out my dear friends over at the
wisecrack channel who just did a video
about Batman V Superman that got me to
look at the whole movie in a completely
new light I mean have you ever stopped
to consider that the movie is commenting
on the similarities between Lex Luthor
and Batman yeah I didn't either but
their video does an amazing job making
it seem like this movie had a lot more
meaning behind it than it actually does
I mean it's still a convoluted mess but
it's almost like they intended it to
have a deeper message one that the
wisecrack team will make you truly
appreciate so make sure that you
Superman
slap that button right there and tell
them that matpat sent you proves that I
have value in life but in all
seriousness guys if you enjoyed this
channel then please check out wisecrack
they're one of the few channels on
YouTube that really do an amazing job of
finding the balance between educational
content but also videos that are funny
and enjoyable to watch they specialize
in videos with a purpose deeper meaning
all while being entertained what more
can you ask for this is the information
age so anything that makes the
information easier to swallow it's
definitely worth your time so please you
owe it to yourself to carve off five
minutes of your time and check them out
odds are you're not gonna be
disappointed or if you want more
theories about the Dark Knight check out
this video where we calculate how Batman
fails Gotham simply by kissing Catwoman
at the end of The Dark Knight Rises
based on the calculations if he hadn't
slipped her the tongue thousands of
lives would have been saved but more on
that over there now if you'll excuse me
I have to roll out
you